à partir du moment où tu veux reprendre
la main sur ton propre temps c'est pas
forcément pour être plus productif c'est
pas ça l'intérêt en fait c'est pas de
faire plein de choses en permanence ça
peut l'être mais pas nécessairement
c'est déjà de faire ce qu'on veut soi et
pour ça il faut savoir nommer les
différentes
[Musique]
il y a dans nos journées du temps dédié
au travail du temps obligatoire du temps
personnel du temps pour soi du nom temps
du temps perdu
ça c'est les psy pour moi non du temps
qu'on consomme dans une journée
si on sait à chaque moment dans quel
temps on est alors on peut maîtriser ça
par exemple si je décide des dons du
temps pour moi en prenant une pose sur
laquelle je vais lire par exemple est-ce
que c'est du temps perdu
est-ce que c'est pas bien que je ne
fasse pas mon travail à ce moment là
c'est ni bien ni mal c'est juste assumer
parce que c'est fait en pleine
conscience et donc ce que je conseille
aux gens c'est de prendre une journée
type voir une semaine c'est encore
meilleur
et de lister tout ce qu'ils ont fait
durant leur semaine mais jusqu'au plus
petit détail et de calcul et après en
temps et en pourcentage
quel pourcentage ils ont passé dans
d'une montant ou dans du temps perdu ou
dans du temps de travail vous donne du
temps obligatoire et à partir du moment
où on a conscience de ça on peut
rectifier ou assumer ou changer ou faire
très peur parce que ce qui fait
extrêmement peur c'est de voir à quel
point on est dans du temps perdu et le
temps perdu il doit pas pouvoir exister
le temps perdu c'est par exemple aller
sur internet pour choper une information
et y être encore une heure après sur un
truc qu'on n'a pas décidé
au départ ça c'est du temps perdu le
temps pour soi n'est jamais du temps
perdu de temps personnel non plus on a
des valeurs comme ça dont il faut se
libérer
c'est pas grave de rien faire c'est pas
grave de prendre du temps mais toujours
en pleine conscience soit l'avoir
décidée et aujourd'hui je veux rien
faire par exemple
oh
j'ai toujours juste une angoisse et sur
les gros projets qu'on n'a pas envie de
faire ou que on se sent pas compétent à
faire ou alors c'est vraiment un sujet
qui nous intéresse pas que ce soit
encore une fois dans la vie perso ou
dans l'afrique pro il ya une très bonne
méthode pour ça qu'ils aient le
découpage et le découpage et les sur
découpage des projets vous devez
imaginons ont lancé un blog je prends un
exemple juste comme ça mais lancé un
blog ça ne veut rien dire si dans votre
agenda ou dans votre boulot de
journaliers marques et lancé un blog
vous ferai jamais c'est trop compliqué
par contre on peut découper toutes les
grandes étapes de ce que s'est lancé un
blog et dans ces grandes étapes on peut
re découper encore les souhaits taper
dans les soutes étape les soussous étape
est peut-être qu'une des premières
étapes s'est trouvé le nom de blog et la
couleur principale est bien les y fait
ça là vous aurez déjà un succès vous
aurez réussi quelque chose vous pourrez
leur ailier il y aura un sentiment aussi
de satisfaction personnelle et
d'accomplissement qui sera bien et est
offert mesure vous allez gravir les
échelles de votre découpage
donc c'est très intéressant de découper
au maximum les projets quand il quand
ils sont trop généraliste ou qui sont
trop présents
[Musique]
il faut savoir quand même que je suis un
procrastinateurs avéré peut-être un des
plus gros qu'il ya eu dans ma génération
à tel point que je n'arrivais pas à
faire quoi que ce soit je ne pourrai
jamais lutté contre qui je suis par
contre pourrait mettre des barrières des
choses en place
une des meilleures barrière c'était de
trouver les buts de ma vie les buts de
ma vie j'étais appelé les mantras le
mode d'emploi pour arriver le plus vite
possible à ces mantras sait on prend une
feuille on liste 1 en vrac durant une
journée entière ou deux jours il faut se
laisser le temps
tous les buts qu'on a dans les toutes
les choses qu'on voudrait avoir faire
accomplir expérimenté ça peut être faire
un saut en parachute mais ça peut être
aussi acheter la dernière console de jeu
on se pose pas de limites on n'est pas
là pour juger on note tout une fois
qu'on a ça on essaie de diviser la liste
par deux en trouvant de nouvelles
phrases qui sont des concepts en fait
qu'ils vont reprendre plusieurs de ses
phrases donc si j'avais acheté une
nouvelle console de jeux
allez dans au parc astérix peut-être que
déjà ces deux phrases je peux les réunir
avec un truc aussi simple que passer du
temps à jouer ça ça peut ça peut
regrouper plusieurs choses et on essaie
comme ça donc de diviser cette liste en
deux une fois qu'elle est divisée en
deux on va encore chercher à trouver des
concepts qui vont réunir des phrases et
c'est là où ça devient un petit peu plus
dur parce qu'il faut c'est presque
philosophique comme travail il faut
trouver un petit peu ce qui relie tout
ça et une fois qu'on a plus que deux
trois quatre phrases là on va chercher
un mot ou deux mots ou trois mots clés
maximum pour représenter en fait toutes
ces phrases là j'ai compris deux choses
que mes mantra à moins de personnel
c'est l'autonomie et la liberté
si j'atteins ces deux choses dans ma vie
alors je suis heureux et mais mantra il
fonctionne un petit peu comme une
boussole c'est comme si dans la marche
avait une boussole et à chaque fois que
j'ai une opportunité qui se présente à
moi ou décision à prendre ou je ne sais
pas n'importe quoi
je regarde en fait si les aiguilles vont
dans le sens de l'autonomie et de la
liberté
si une des deux n'y va pas je fais pas
et si les deux nippons pas je fuis en
courant et ça tout le monde peut le
faire et je vous assure que ça vous
enlève une charge mentale terrible de
savoir enfin pour une fois qu'elles sont
les mots qui vous rendent heureux sans
paraître défaitiste on est là un
claquement de doigts sur terre il ya une
règle c'est que chaque matin on se
réveille on a mille quatre cent quarante
minutes à dépenser elles peuvent pas se
cumuler c'est pas comme de l'argent on
peut pas le mettre sur un conte un peu
pour plus tard faut le consommer quoi
qu'il arrive et si on veut pas le
consommer ils se consommera tout seul et
on a ce cadeau là tous les jours
peut-être parce que ça peut s'arrêter
dans une heure une fois que tu as
compris ça t'as tout compris quoi la
seule l'urgence c'est d'être heureux et
d'expérimenter